[Música]
Ecuador vive el primer litigio penal de
su historia por trata de personas con
fines de explotación laboral se acusa de
ejercer esclavitud moderna a la
multinacional furucahua plantaciones
productora de la planta de abacá que
luego se convierte en papel moneda tanto
la compañía como sus directivos serán
sometidos a juicio Este es un caso que
han reportado al detalle medios como el
país y que incluye la servidumbre desde
bebés de dos años hasta adultos mayores
que son obligados a trabajar por
remuneraciones y muy por debajo de la
ley además sin días de descanso con
accidentes laborales y con mutilaciones
que nunca fueron atendidas vamos a
hablar de este caso gravísimo o con
Alejandra Zambrano quien es abogada
miembro del equipo de litigio de este
caso Gracias Alejandro por estar en
directo a América y nos acompaña además
en el estudio mi compañera Marta Moya
quien ha estado indagando también sobre
este tema Si le parece bien pues vamos a
comenzar Alejandra con las preguntas
y para empezar le voy a leer un extracto
de el artículo que publicó el país
dedicado al tema familias pobres ningún
estudio toda una vida dedicada a la vaca
y una empresa que según lo que narran
los demandantes cerraba la puerta
carrozable con candado de lunes a lunes
Cuáles eran las condiciones de vida
basándose en los testimonios de los
trabajadores
Hola Buenos días Ángela Buenos días a
todas las personas que nos escuchan
bueno el caso realmente como acabas de
detallar tan brevemente es muy grave hay
se han configurado condiciones de vida y
de trabajo que configuran una práctica
análoga la esclavitud que el derecho
internacional lo denomina servidumbre de
la gleva Y es de la gleva porque está
atado a la tierra las personas viven y
trabajan en la tierra propiedad de la
compañía furukawa que es propietario de
aproximadamente dos mil trescientas
hectáreas distribuidas en tres
provincias de Ecuador en alrededor de 23
haciendas dentro de cada Hacienda hay
infraestructuras campamentos y es allí
en donde eran acogidos han sido acogidos
por décadas la compañía funciona desde
los años 60 por lo que hay una presencia
intergeneracional de personas de
familias que se han visto sometidas a
este tipo de trabajo del que de una
manera cíclica no logran salir son
personas que están muy e no solamente
porque reciben remuneraciones por debajo
de la ley sino porque también sus
condiciones la falta de acceso a otro
tipo de derechos Como salud como
educación hay un noventa y cinco por
ciento de analfabetismo por ejemplo hay
muchísimos accidentes de trabajo las
personas cuando llegó el estado en fines
de 2018 las encontraron a muchas sin
registro de identidades es decir no
constaban como nacidos no existían para
el Estado ecuatoriano además el 60%
aproximadamente son personas
afrodescendientes que conocemos esa es
una realidad transversal para toda
América Latina Cuál es la situación de
exclusión que vive este grupo entonces
todas estas circunstancias son las que
los volvieron vulnerables para que se
Cometa contra ellos esta explotación
laboral que también según criterio de
fiscalía también Configura una práctica
de un delito de tráfico Perdón trata de
personas con fines de explotación
laboral incluido el trabajo infantil
Hola señora Zambrano Buenos días yo le
quería preguntar en la última audiencia
vimos que la jueza apelaba un poco a ese
papel que juega el estado Por qué es
importante que la jueza haga esta
reflexión
Sí fue muy importante fue muy
significativo que la jueza Susana
sotomayora haya hecho esta mención el
proceso al que hace referencia Marta es
el proceso penal no fue la decisión de
la jueza de llamar a juicio estamos
recién iniciando esta esta etapa sin y
esto se sigue en contra de la persona
jurídica furuncagua plantaciones y de
varias personas naturales que fue que
son directivos de esta compañía pero el
llamado que hace la jueza sotomayor se
refiere Cuál es la responsabilidad del
Estado porque el estado ha favorecido o
no ha hecho la suficientes actividades
de control para que que han permitido
que han propiciado que se dé esta
situación entonces por eso la jueza
sotomayor iniciaba así su intervención
diciendo dónde estuvo el estado
ecuatoriano ahora la responsabilidad del
también se está discutiendo
judicialmente pero en otro proceso en
una acción de una acción de protección
que es un poco similar a la de tutela
que tienen allá en Colombia que es un
proceso que ya está iniciado que tiene
ya sentencia de primera instancia
apelación y que actualmente se encuentra
en análisis de la corte constitucional
qué es lo que dice la otra parte en este
litigio Alejandra porque Pese a que
muchos trabajadores llegaron siendo
bebés nunca recibieron educación o una
vida digna como usted nos ha descrito la
defensa lega que tenían agua potable que
tenían luces y hasta con mofa se puede
tomar una declaración de uno de los
abogados que decía que tenían hasta
directo y bien las haciendas
bueno eso lo dicen nivel de vocerías en
los medios de comunicación en el proceso
Ninguno de los abogados de los
procesados niega los hechos niega las
condiciones de vida y de trabajo de las
personas la defensa de ellos se basan
más bien en señalar que ellos no fueron
que no fue un gerente porque él recién
llegó en el 2019 otro dice que él no ha
firmado nada otra persona dice yo era un
simple empleado yo solamente me decía
órdenes entonces son posiciones así de
este tipo pero nadie niega los hechos
los hechos son irrefutables Ángel a
Marta Hay muchísimas informes incluso
resoluciones sancionatorias del
Ministerio de trabajo de Ecuador por
trabajo infantil y que no solamente por
una ocasión sino que hubo reincidencia
eso llevó a que en el año 2019 la
compañía estuviera cerrada por tres
meses
yo le quería preguntar también señora
Zambrano si este caso ha tenido la
repercusión que parece que amerita en
Ecuador
en principio sí cuando el caso se hizo
público en febrero de 2019 la defensoría
del pueblo emitió este informe y
simultáneamente salieron una serie de
reportajes de dos medios digitales de
acá de Ecuador la barra espaciadora y
Plan B y allí Sí el caso fue muy hablado
discutido pero luego de unos meses de
eso decayó de hecho enfrentamos por
varios años un cerco mediático los
medios grandes de acá de Ecuador no le
han dado la cobertura que la gravedad de
los cachos desde el caso amerita sino
que más bien ha sido a nivel de medios
que circulan más en redes sociales en
donde se ha hecho una un mayor
seguimiento del caso
y finalmente Alejandra ya nos vamos
quedando sin tiempo pero creemos que lo
más importante aquí es enfocarnos en las
víctimas y en lo que ellas necesitan
como reparación Cómo ha sido el camino
de estos trabajadores para llegar hasta
lo que representa este litigio
para ellos ha sido muy difícil ellos ya
vivían en una situación de
empobrecimiento como acabo de señalar de
pobreza y extrema pobreza que acá en
Ecuador estamos hablando de ingresos
mensuales inferiores a los ochenta o
cuarenta dólares que es bajísimo
entonces después de que el caso se hace
público y empiezan los procesos pues
para ellos ha sido muy difícil porque
por obvias razones ya no trabajan para
la empresa la gran mayoría lo único que
saben hacer es el cultivo de abacán no
encuentran trabajos en otros lugares no
saben leer y escribir entonces la
situación de ellos ha sido bastante
compleja fueron desplazados también de
los campamentos porque la estrategia que
utilizó la empresa cuando el caso se
hace público en 2019 fue derrocar los
campamentos con eso logró que la gente
se disperse Y que cuando llegaran las
autoridades dijeron que ya ahí no hay
nadie y también pues eliminar la las
infraestructuras que como digo esos eran
los lugares de acogida para la gente sin
embargo hay una sola en donde un grupo
de personas que aproximadamente hoy Son
unas veinte treinta personas se
encuentran en resistencia protegiendo
ese campamento pero también no no lo
hacen por una parte para protegerlo y
que las autoridades puedan seguir
llegando a hacer inspecciones pero
también lo hacen porque son los más
empobrecidos y no tienen otro lugar en
donde vivir las reparaciones que
nosotros estamos solicitando tanto en el
proceso constitucional como en el
proceso penal son económicas
evidentemente pero en el proceso
constitucional hay un poco más de un
margen mayor para solicitar también por
ejemplo medidas simbólicas medidas
incluso nosotros consideramos que este
caso amerita que haga como medidas de no
repetición que se haga un profundo
análisis de Cuál es la política pública
que se aplica acá en Ecuador para
atender este tipo de casos para no
solamente la recuperación la
rehabilitación de las víctimas sino
también en general Cuál es la política
de inclusión social que permite que
grupos de personas que históricamente
han sido excluidos discriminados no
puedan tener acceso a cuestiones tan
básicas como son la educación o la salud
es que evidentemente esa política no
existe y este caso lo deja más que
demostrado Alejandra Zambrano abogado
del equipo que está en este litigio por
el primer caso de esclavitud moderna en
el país es gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros parece una historia de terror
este caso Franz 24 seguirá con con la
revisión de todo el proceso y haciendo
el seguimiento que corresponde a usted
Gracias a Marta usted Gracias también
por el acompañamiento y a nuestros
televidentes Les pedimos que sigan con
nosotros hoy ya volvemos con más en
directo a América
[Música]